hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about
phenylketonuria so phenylketonuria
is one of the genetic disease caused by
the problem in amino acid metabolism
phenylketonuria is quite rare and its
frequency of
occurrence is 1 out of 15k right so it's
pretty much rare
now phenylketonuria occurs due to a
problem in
phenylalanine metabolism and
phenylalanine metabolism is very
important for our
body so let's take a look at
phenylalanine metabolism to understand
this process
phenylalanine gets converted to tyrosine
with the help of enzyme phenylalanine
hydroxylase
now just like any other enzyme
phenylalanine hydroxylase is encoded by
a gene and this gene is known as
phenylalanine hydroxylase gene
now this gene give rise to the mrna of
these phenylalanine hydroxylase which
forms a functional protein but in case
of phenylketonuria
there is often a mutation in these
phenylalanine hydroxylase gene
which results in production of a
phenylalanine hydroxylase which is
non-functional
as a result we don't see
tyrosine production in case of
phenylketonuria
so phenylalanine cannot be hydroxylated
to form
tyrosine tyrosine
is very important for our body's
physiology
i'll tell you why tyrosine can produce
dopamine in the brain which is a very
essential neurotransmitter
it can give rise to t3 and t4 hormones
in the thyroid gland so it's also
important for endocrinology
it also give rise to melanin which is
the skin pigment
tyrosine is also involved in production
of cathola mine such as epinephrine
norepinephrine in the
adrenal cortex so all these things make
tyrosine very important
in case of phenylketonuria there would
be a deficiency of tyrosine
because phenylalanine cannot be
converted so
that leads to a barrage of problems
first of all in the brain tyrosine can
give rise to many neurotransmitters that
we have looked norepinephrine
epinephrine and dopamine so when
tyrosine levels are low
all these neurotransmitters won't be
produced
moreover when phenylalanine level is
high
it prevents tyrosine and tryptophan to
be uptaken by the brain
let me remind you that tyrosine
tryptophan and phenylalanine are uptaken
by the brain with the same
transporter a phenylalanine level rises
abruptly
so it would occupy all of these
transporter in the brain
and won't allow tryptophan or tyrosine
to get in
so these amino acids that means
tryptophan and tyrosine they are
precursor for serotonin and dopamine
and as a result the brain would have low
level of
dopamine and serotonin collectively all
these phenomena
lead to a cognitive impairment
in phenylketonuria patient and this is
pretty normal
other symptoms involving phenylketonuria
includes intellectual disabilities
seizure behavioral problems and mental
disorders
now let me tell you that phenylketonuria
is a autosomal recessive
that means if father and mother are the
carrier at least
they have one copy of these mutation
then
50 percent of their children would be
carrier
one 25 percent would be unaffected and
25 percent would be totally affected
now phenylketonuria screening is
generally done
after the week of birth i mean at least
in the advanced countries the first
world countries
so actually a blood sample
is taken from the heel of this baby
and that is analyzed for phenylalanine
levels
if phenylalanine level is increased in
the blood
that is indicative of phenylketonuria
further genetic testing is done to
confirm this observation
now let us summarize um what we can
learn about uh phenylketonuria so first
of all
phenylketonuria level uh
increase in brain can lead to toxicity
in the brain now till then there is no
cure of phenylketonuria because it's a
genetic disease
however if diagnosed early then proper
dietary plan
can save the baby or set the brain from
this kind of adverse effect
obviously since the body cannot
metabolize phenol
phenyl alanine in this condition so the
diet which is rich with phenylalanine
these foods should be avoided such as
fish meat dairy products etc
other than that the diets which are
low in phenylalanine levels such as many
leafy vegetables and fruit
can be taken now let me tell you
phenylalanine phenylalanine in absence
of being converted to tyrosine now gets
converted to phenyl pyruvate by the help
of
transamination reaction so any amino
acid undergoes transamination reaction
so
the rate of transamination increase when
phenylalanine hydroxylase is not present
or non-functional so phenyl pyruvate
gets further converted to phenyl
acetaldehyde or phenyl ethanol so this
phenyl pyruvate phenyl acetaldehyde
phenyl acetate these things are
phenylketones
right or we can understand these
phenylketones
are actually secreted into the urine
and the presence of this phenyl acetate
lactate gives urine a mousy odor
this suggests that phenylketonuria
simply means
phenylketones in the urine and the
nomenclature is pretty much
pretty much apt right now let me tell
you that phenylketon
phenylketonuria also could be associated
with
hypopigmentation because phenylalanine
give rise to several
intermediate in this biosynthetic
pathway which is dopaquinone
and dopaquinone gets converted to pheo
melanin or eu melanines
these are responsible for our skin tone
and skin color
so whenever we don't have phenylalanine
to tyrosine
conversion this pathway is abrogated as
a result
the skin pigmentation can be perturbed
or the skin pigmentation can be uh
low or the skin skin could be
hyperpigmented
so all these are consequence of phenyl
kitchen area so let us talk about the
summary phenylketonuria is one of the
metabolic disease
which is frequently occurring um and
it's
it is due to the problem in amino acid
metabolism pathway
so the key enzyme which is
involved in this process is
phenylalanine
hydroxylase which converts phenylalanine
to tyrosine and this particular enzyme
is non-functional due to the genetic
problem phenylketonuria also is
associated with
cognitive impairment and several
neurological problems
phenylketonuria is not curable
however if diagnosed early it can be
managed and with proper dietary plan a
person can survive for a long time
and these mental retardation can be
prevented in that case as well so all
these are summary of phenylketonuria i
hope you enjoyed this video if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up and
don't forget to like share and subscribe
thank you